[Music]
you guys know that in korea everybody
has to enlist for the military at some
point before a certain age a lot a lot
of asian countries have it loki's kind
of fire off
not japan japan's just doing j-pop [ __ ]
dude because you have to do that in
taiwan too malaysia has that too i think
israel is big on that apparently japan's
got american military station there so
they're like thank you
i personally think it's a pretty cool
thing i think so too
what do you think would exempt somebody
from that from having to do that at all
health problems mental or physical
disabilities two left feet two left feet
are there are there they're missing
they're missing one or two or more legs
one or two or more oh there's a
caretaking situation yeah cover all the
basically like for example if i was the
only child and then like my dad was
passed away or something my mom was ill
and like she was young i was your
caretaker iq but isn't it usually just
training for the most part like training
and then they might put them in like a
job or something but not like
necessarily see combat that's what i
like about it yeah like a lot of them i
think that's
mandatory i think yeah a lot of them
it's not like guaranteed going to war a
lot of it is just training and i that's
what i'm really like reserved it's like
boot camp just in case they have to uh
mobilize but then it's long though it's
like a year or two somewhere a year boot
camp no no no
the service yeah oh so it's like you're
like a reserve but you're doing
different roles right like
military police or like a wine chef like
a year or two or three some of them so
it's always kind of been a thing
whenever anyone in korea
gets really famous as a superstar
internationally it's always a thing of
like oh what's gonna happen when they
have to serve uh for for b boys in korea
that get really popular they just have
to stop breaking and they have to go do
the thing and you just don't see them
anymore
uh like like like break dancers yeah
what uh what age they have to go like 18
or so you have until 28 and i think it
just got pushed to be at 30. so when
you're a k-pop star it's like and you
see like your career skyrocket when
you're like 17 or something
and then that's when they're like oh i
don't know if i could take a break from
my tour
but which is why you go you you'll go
when you're like 28. yeah that's why
like i remembered a lot gotta get to
choose the window a little bit yeah you
can yeah that's kind of cool i remember
growing up like when there were like uh
when there was a huge boom in like
korean dancers just like taking over the
scene and they had such a limited amount
of time to like get their to make their
mark and then they would just be gone
and it was like a crazy thing that like
and now in a way it was kind of
motivating because you knew that like oh
[ __ ] only have this window time or some
fled remember that and some did some
came here and just like didn't go back
to korea and now they can never go back
because if they go back they're gonna
have to you know that's kind of cool too
though but um and it's been a known
thing all obviously everyone's like
what's going to happen to bts like
what's going to happen to them what
they're doing all this stuff and it's
always been a known thing that they were
going to try to get them exempt but
south korea's culture minister has
actually called for their exemption from
military service so it's not going to
happen huh has called for their
exemption yeah so they don't have to go
to military
they're trying to figure out within that
two-year
service if they can just do a different
thing
that actually benefits korea within what
they're already doing because i thought
that the um the what do you call it like
the tourism board or the basically yeah
the government spends money on exporting
korean culture and they consider now
like k-pop and all this stuff
as one of those vehicles of you know
getting people's you know but wasn't
like taehyung who was huge k-pop as well
instead what they did he also still had
to go to the military um in training and
stuff like that but he would just go
around to all the military bases and
perform like uso shows basically yeah so
you're still doing your thing but you
just have to do it within the confines
of being with them yeah that's true
because fulfill yourself let's say
you're like gordon ramsay right young
gordon ramsay right you cook and [ __ ]
you're useless behind a [ __ ] gun yeah
put them behind a kitchen like a [ __ ]
poodle behind a pan you know
that's doing service think about all the
morale he would boost you know how the
delicious food is go to world war ii
i don't know if he actually went to
where i thought he was just i think he
performed at war no i think you're
thinking about captain america is
propaganda oh my bad yeah i think i'm
thinking of elvis actually i i saw elvis
in a uniform
in hawaii right yeah he served he served
in the army nineteen fifty eight okay
that's right why would he be well that's
after world war ii i don't know if he
went he necessarily was deployed but
yeah he but see that was a cool thing
because that was a huge point of
american pride that he still put his
guitar down and was like i'm going yeah
you know and jimmy stewart went in
i don't know if that would get you the
same props um today what do you think
same props today i don't think we're as
patriotic as we are before well what
about pat telling the football player
pat tillman yeah when pat tell me when
everyone still talks about i think that
that that era i think people are super
patriotic i almost feel like in this day
and age i don't know if it started in
2020 or whatever but the the consensus
is like america sucks or it feels that
way it feels like a lot of americans
think america's according to american
research yeah
you're from other americans you're from
a military family are you the only one
aside from your sister that didn't go
yeah i'm the biggest [ __ ] in the whole
family you feel do you feel like
like you're you're like i didn't follow
in my military family footsteps 100 it's
only funny because it's true yeah i
think about it all the time actually
about how what a [ __ ] i am yeah
because i just wanted to rub that in
yeah no i appreciate it yeah
i mean my grandpa was always like don't
[ __ ] do marines because it's way too
hard you don't want to do marines wait
so he's proud of the marines but he
looked at you and said don't do it well
that means he told my dad and like my
uncles and stuff oh he told his old kids
not to do it yeah it wasn't just you
when my dad met him my dad was only like
17 18 years old so so then he's like
chuck don't go in the [ __ ] marines
they'll kill you he's like go he's like
go dude go to the chair force nobody
gives a [ __ ] about those guys anyway
chair force
and so yeah so that's that's what i did
most marines when you ask them like if
you were to redo your like career over
again what would you do all of them are
like i'll probably join the army
including dawn including these dogs so
what what gets people to join the
marines in the first i think what it's
it's that like almost elitism the
prestige it's like okay they're the few
and the proud
they're they get the toughest [ __ ] it's
the hardest [ __ ] training but when
you go through it and you start learning
like best ways to learn you realize
it doesn't need to be that hard for
every single thing that you do yeah like
in other like funnels like let's say the
army or whatever uh or even air force
because they have their own special ops
too it's like boot camp is for general
people let's make it generally hard if
you go up to another school and it's a
little bit
more difficult make that a little bit
harder so in the army by the time you
get to green berets or rangers or uh in
the air force their special ops is the
pjs it's extremely hard and it's on on
the same level as navy seals like bud's
week and hell week but it's built up
that way
marine corps boot camp is just [ __ ]
extremely hard right at the get-go so
most people they join in like [ __ ] a
year later they're so burnt out they're
like i'm so [ __ ] burnt out but had i
done the army or the army route i might
have stayed in for 20 years hmm you know
so that's what my brothers both did
chair force like boot camp and they were
they're both saying how that all they
met was [ __ ] idiots so anybody could
do this [ __ ]
it was great and that's encouraging and
my brother also hurt his back in there
like in the air force he hurt his back
but he was because of the chair he was
sitting in the chair the whole time was
his [ __ ] point
because he he was actually sitting in
chair the whole time he slipped the disc
and then when he went to the the city's
bad for you dude pt guys
they had him doing these weight
lifting things that [ __ ] his back up
even harder
yeah now he gets disability and all he
did was sit in the [ __ ] chair in the
air force this ability air forces
uh you get a salary for like the rest of
your life oh my god yo that's pretty
dope wow
i almost wish i fell off a cliff before
i came back
you're just like looking for clips the
whole time on your last day out don't
people hella do that though like try and
injure themselves before they balance i
don't know maybe i don't know so marine
dudes they um they go through it and
they see what it's really like and then
they compare it to other like companies
and then they'll be like oh man actually
it probably would have been better if i
went navy first or if i went like army
first and then um
but that's still the prestige of being a
read it's still so high that people that
don't know they still want to join
because it's almost like it's that
personality type right so when you have
like let's say someone that has gone
through it and like let's say he's
thinking about joining the military if
he's like the marine personality type
i'm like dude this shit's so [ __ ]
hard you don't want to do it trust me
he's like he's salivating at the mouth i
gotta do it of course i have to do i'm
not a [ __ ] you know what i mean it's
like because then
that almost has that reverse effect
where it makes people go oh you're
telling us the hardest and i have to
deal with it yeah
you know art is the most bart is the
most um
marine marine i've met because well no
because there are there are marines that
that you meet where it's like they can't
shut the [ __ ] up about the marines and
you know that's the real marine world
well that's what i mean because you're
an actual to me you're you're a real one
because my grandpa didn't [ __ ] talk
about it either you know what i mean
like he'll talk about it like if you ask
him questions but he doesn't [ __ ]
talk those are marines there's a real
marine yeah yeah yeah they're not going
super fun
did you say who roger
at the gym you guys have a discount for
marines and up charge for navy yeah yeah
yeah i charge them are you a poser
marine or a real man yeah do you have a
chair for chair force guys
chair exercises
have a seat sir welcome to the club
thank you
do you feel like if uh like the again
i'm not from cruise or anything like
that but it'd be like kind of a slippery
slope to uh enable you know like bts for
example no matter how popular they are i
mean it's still a it's still a steep
slope to catch up to what they're doing
yeah do what bts does and you get
examples
what's next right like what's the next
thing usually the second thing that gets
exempt is usually already way easier
than what the first people have to do if
you get your own mcdonald's meal dude
you could do it the [ __ ] you want
[Laughter]
because even like um again i'm not
explicitly saying i don't know these are
[ __ ] rumors or whatever but i
remember even when the hong kong i think
hong kong was still doing the the uh
marines uh military services is a star b
boy that like changed the world of
breaking yeah and he was uh he was a
rebel bc one champion and he was the
second b-boy in the world to be a
two-time rebel bc1 champion and he did
it at like a decade apart in the 10-year
anniversary it was in korea for red bull
bc one again um and they were doing all
the old champions come together so he
was the champion of champions but i
heard
that he was in military service during
that time and he snuck out because he
was still in korea and he competed for
rebel bc one won it and then went back
that's pretty good because still within
the country but you know what i mean
it's like if i i would assume that even
for like such a high profile you know
group like bts like
if they're gonna exempt anything it
would still make sense for them to
fulfill their duty as an example to the
rest of korea even but then obviously
there are exemptions within their time
that they're doing they should be able
to do both yeah if there's compromises
like that that'd be really sick like
there are people that uh like play in
the olympics from the military and um or
play a professional sport actually army
navy football yeah like the election
they'll get exempt for the game or maybe
even a little window before and after
but right when they're done they go
right back to what their normal platoon
is but then you'd still yeah the
compromise is it's still like dang even
bts still wins the army that would be so
encouraging or inspiring if i was like a
young person or people would want to go
especially if you're trying to build
patriotism yeah that's great yeah that's
true or else this is this could be the
start of unraveling that like extreme
korean patriotism that we know about you
guys think that they actually sat down
and figured out what they wanted their
bts meal to be yeah i think about that
too like seven dudes can agree on one
[ __ ] meal like their favorite their
favorite [ __ ] like there's no way they
all were just like yeah it could have
just been a seven piece mcnugget but it
was pretty basic though wasn't it
it was it was like a cheeseburger with
some nuggets solid
can't beat that bts comes in for the
extreme collab we're changing from six
piece to seven that'd be pretty tight
right a seven piece mcnugget that's the
only thing different if we had to pick a
mcdonald's meal right now i think we
would all have a difference of opinion
it'd be a combo meal just like the bts
guys after three everybody say the same
exact same time yeah one two three big
mac combo
the chicken nugget did you say fish
quarterback i said a fellow fish and
quarter pounder and nuggets
that's what i was getting in a soda wait
a fella fish add a quarter pounder one
meal and and nuggets
and a soda and then i get caught up with
mac sauce that way everyone's happy bro
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you